you guys got a setup mom so much work
sitting it closer to me get closer
yeah closer mom what are you afraid to
get closer to me you can see half your
face I don't draw that out of the camera
you have to be like this right in the
frame
I don't want you're gonna be in the
frame I don't want to hey guys I'm Ryan
right I wanna be this is my mother Joyce
and this is Mary black and this is Mary
black my sister it's Mother's Day today
so I thought I'll bring my family on the
channel to watch the x-men days of
future past Quicksilver trailer do you
want to see that movie maybe do you want
to see it never heard of it
you read the comics right mom no I
thought you did not x-men what do you
read Superman it's pretty cool that she
read comics isn't it Batman
mom keep your face in the frame what are
you doing I'm gonna move this back more
since you guys are the worst people to
cooperated with me huh you know I saw
the first x-men with my mom actually
that was cool
I remember it's whispering do you
remember that I remember whispering to
my mom this is a really good movie then
I saw it again with my dad and he's a
lot more sensitive than my mom I think
cuz when Wolverine's claw came out for
the first time my dad went like this
yeah he freaked out
Mary you're not in the frame okay good
gosh man they're just like me they're
just as social of me yeah she doesn't
want to be here I had to convince her to
sit here anyway yeah special Mother's
Day shut up with fillings is a special
Mother's Day video let's enjoy this
trailer people I thought Professor X
died yeah I'm sure it'll be a brief
explanation how does that happen
I don't know no maintenance the mutants
anything's possible in this universe
you're about to see the most bland
reactions from the extraordinary powers
sexy the next stage in human evolution
it's quick solid he's a great actor I
won't forget that is the culture
truely's whoa
the bad guy now change ah see damn you
looks cool I know a guy he could get it
anyway teleport and always his fast wow
the effexor is amazing you nothing
anybody would believe if you told these
fascinating that looks really cool right
mother you say so
what about you married ah marry try and
make sure I don't make any sex jokes
tonight I get uncomfortable especially
being this close to my mom to make us
extra that's good I want to watch it
yeah we'll go together mom as a Mother's
Day gift as I owe you a gift my gift to
you was putting you on the channel enjoy
it chew it up okay how's it a fail oh
yeah that movie does look really awesome
and I wasn't expecting to see that cool
effects because they haven't teased
anything like that at all on the other
trailers so Quicksilver is gonna be
awesome people were concerned about the
costume at first guys but I think it's
gonna be alright
hey feedback good feedback have you not
seen as Carl's jr. commercial no I
haven't seen his Carl's jr. commercial
but I know that's what he's famous for
okay guys so if you're new to the
channel I tell people to subscribe at
this point subscribe there's a button up
here and you want to click that button
to subscribe
yes please yeah right please listen to
my mom please listen to her I beg you
please she wants me to be successful for
us I gotta go back to school full-time
both OH
you'll learn something oh I don't care
two line so here's what I like to do at
the end of each video I like to give
shout outs to people and we go an order
of the list and some people lately have
been getting mad that I don't shout them
out because they think right when they
ask they're supposed to be next but hey
there's over a hundred requests so chill
out people it's Mother's Day appreciate
your mom and don't get mad at me right
right right
so Frankie Thomas he said he's a beard
enthusiast you like my beard you don't
like my facial hair
you don't like facial hair on guys do
you know you like dads facial hair no
dad what about you
oh my go tease only go tease like Tony
Stark mm-hmm really to go tease anyway
I'm glad you're a beard enthusiast my
friend thanks for telling me that
because I have a good beard I'm hoping
tell me if I should shave actually don't
tell me I know a lot of you gonna tell
me that I like my facial hair
Catholic school they don't allow you to
have facial hair what are you doing is
it back in pain I'm tired okay God they
know how to spice up things with a
camera damn fat boys that's a cool name
is there multiple of you are you fat is
that the thing are you actually is it so
sleepy h80
because if you're fat I mean good
embrace it that's what I started doing
and now I'm finally working out again so
beef fat and eat up don't eat it too
much there's things such as cholesterol
and stuff like that triglycerides and
make another supersize me video yeah
make a super steena when I saw supersize
me that just made me want to eat more
weekly and last person Shawn what lates
blurs flat alerts we you guys have the
weirdest freakin names
you wanted a shout out so mom shut him
out who you're going to just mention
Shawn let others lead over flatterers
Shawn what labelers leathers leather er
lapped alerts
Shawn letters there you go see ya see no
Mary do it Shawn letter yeah Shawn
modelers good for you there's your
shout-out buddy
enjoy it anyway guys hope you have a
wonderful Mother's Day appreciate your
mom and if you don't appreciate your mom
shame on you
because without your mom pushing you out
of her vagina you would not be here I
was a c-section you know I was a
c-section right okay I'm asking she was
there I'm tasking you as if you wouldn't
remember I was a stupid baby I was like
rolling around in my mom's stomach and
the cord got wrapped around my neck my
heart kept stopping but as a baby I saw
an angel appear and the angel said and
house not your times I survived do an
awesome c-section now my mom has a scar
because of me scarred for life just like
all the women who have scarred me in my
life
dan Asian chicks knives Aaron gay
hey would you be mad if I became gay oh
no no you be cool with it that's a cool
mom right there I'm going gay